et puis après cette annonce de Berlin il
y a eu pas mal de réactions bien sûr de
la part des partenaires de l'Allemagne à
Bruxelles on va retrouver pierre Bénazet
notre correspondant pierre bonjour
d'autres pays devrait suivre c'est le
cas notamment de l'Espagne et ainsi
livré aussi des chars
il y a plusieurs pays en Europe au sein
de l'OTAN qui possède un grand nombre de
ces chars léopards modèle 2 surtout dans
l'OTAN c'est la Turquie et la Grèce mais
l'Espagne aurait plus de 320 chars
léopard 2 elle ne dit pas pour l'instant
la ministre espagnol de la défense
combien de Charles léopard l'Espagne
pourrait livrer à l'Ukraine mais en
revanche effectivement c'est désormais
évoqué officiellement et expressément
par l'Espagne une livraison prévisible
donc parmi les autres pays qui ont déjà
donné des indications on sait que les
Pays-Bas qui eux aussi ont moins de 250
Charles léopard 2 sont prêts à en donner
le Premier ministre m'a recruteux a
évoqué le chiffre de 18 chars léopard
pour les autres c'est un peu moins clair
pour l'instant on sait que la Pologne
qui est en pointe sur ce dossier depuis
le départ veut livrer des Charlie au
paradiscrènes et former des équipages de
charruesiens et les Pays-Bas parmi les
Pays-Bas c'est le cas aussi et c'est
surtout la Finlande la Finlande qui est
désormais en première ligne avec ses
1300 km de frontières partagées avec la
Russie la Finlande possède plusieurs
centaines de chars léopard elle n'en
donnera pas énormément mais elle annonce
aujourd'hui officiellement qu'elle veut
participer à cet envoi de Charles
léopard 2 à l'Ukraine ça participe du
soutien de cette coalition dont la
Pologne parle depuis des semaines
maintenant la Pologne évoque une
quinzaine de pays à travers le à travers
l'Europe et l'OTAN puisque le Canada
aussi possède des chars léopard et
pourrait envisager de se joindre à cette
coalition ce qui n'est pas encore il n'y
a pas encore d'annonce formelle de la
part du Kavala non plus merci beaucoup
pierre Bénazet depuis Bruxelles et